يعتبر مقياس ريختار احد ادقهم مقاييس
الزلازل في العالم واكثرها كفاءه وانتشارا
يقوم على نظام رقمي لوغاريتمي ويعتمد في
تحديد قوه الزلزال على الجانب الكمي وعلى
مقدار الطاقه المنبعثه من بؤره الزلزال
ينسب الى العالم الامريكي تشارليز فرانسيس
الذي اخترعه عام
1935 من الناحيه النظريه يتدرج مقياس
ريختر من درجه واحده الى تسع درجات رغم
انه من الناحيه العمليه يمكن ان يصل الى
اكثر من ذلك من صفر الى اربع درجات يتدرج
وصف قوه الزلزال من المجهريه الى الطفيفه
ويمكن ان يشعر به الانسان لكنه لا يتسبب
باي اضرار من الدرجه الرابعه الى الخامسه
يوصف بالخفيف يمكن ان يحرك الاشياء وقد
يتسبب بتحطم زجاج بعض المنازل لكن اضراره
تكون محدوده من الخامسه وحتى السادسه يوصف
بالمعتدل يمكنه ان يلحق دمارا بالمباني
الضعيفه وان يتسبب بظهور التشققات في
جدران المنازل والشوارع من السادسه الى
السابعه يوصف بالقوي ويمكن ان يحدث دمارا
وانهيارا للمباني حتى على بعد 160
كيلومترا من بؤره الزلزال من الدرجه
السابعه وحتى الثامنه يوصف بالكبير ويحدث
دمارا كبيرا وانهيارا واسعا للمباني وقد
يتسبب بزوال مناطق باكملها
الزلزال العظيم هو الذي تصل قوته من ثماني
درجات وحتى ما دون العاشره ويمكنه ان يمحو
مدنا باكملها عن الوجود وتصل اضراره
الكبيره حتى مئات الكيلومترات واحيانا
الاف عن بؤره حدوثه
وبما ان مقياس ريختر هو مقياس لوغاريتميون
اساسه 10 بمعنى ان قوه الزلزال هي ذاتها
القوه التي يرفع اليها الرقم عشره لذلك
فان الدرجه السابعه هي اكثر قوه من الدرجه
السادسه بعشره اضعاف ومن الدرجه الخامسه
بمائه ضعف
[موسيقى]